i just want to start quickly by talking
about the leadership contest and we had
interviews of course with two candidates
today who would later be most scared of
fighting at a general election
oh i think you've got this chaotic
catwalk of contestants now who are all
been defending boris johnson for the
last few
years who've also all been part of 12
years of failed conservative government
with low growth with uh soaring cost of
living and also run down public services
so i think all of them and they're all
continuing to defend boris johnson
staying in post right now when frankly
he should be gone um i think all of them
are really part of this catalogue of
failure though all of them been letting
the country down and that's why we don't
think any of them are right for the
country we need a fresh start a better
future for britain
okay you were mentioning there about
boris johnson staying in post till
autumn on thursday kirstama said that if
he does try to do that then labour will
call a vote of no confidence is that
still a plan
yeah i think the problem is that you
have somebody who is still in downing
street who no one thinks has any duties
any sense of duty to the country who's
been responsible for lies for law
breaking and also today's allegations
around abuse of power towards a young
woman while he was the mayor of london
and the point you raised in your
introduction the serious security breach
that appears to have happened while he
was foreign secretary meeting with an
ex-kgb agent
straight after going to a nato summit to
discuss russia at the height of the
salisbury crisis and going without
officials going without any security
apparently going with a guest who has
never been disclosed
serious security questions about that
nobody feels confident that boris
johnson is going to do what is right for
the country that's why he should be gone
now and all of the conservative
candidates who you've been uh
interviewing they should all be
supporting him leaving now before he
does any more damage
you're gonna have to rely if you are
gonna push this fake through on a
substantial number of tory rebels but
you know isn't it likely to have the
kind of opposite effect you're really
kind of uniting the conservative party
against a common enemy here
i think they've got to consider do they
really want to support him carrying on
as you said potentially making more
peers in a completely inappropriate way
but also nobody has confidence that he
is going to do what's right for the
country in the meantime even as a
caretaker prime minister because he has
so badly lost trust and it's clearly
just all about himself so i think that's
what all of the candidates and all of
the conservative party need to be uh
taking very seriously is what is in the
interests of the country what do we now
need to do
to deal with these 12 years of lost
growth for 12 years of wages falling
behind 12 years of damage to crucial
public services like neighborhood
policing that's been lost or on the nhs
that has been run down with waiting
lists soaring time and again i just
think the conservatives have no answers
to this it's only the labor party that's
been setting out a proper plan for the
cost of living with the windfall tax on
the oil and gas companies to then cut
people's energy bills to actually help
people through this crisis it's only
labor that's got a proper plan to grow
the economy that's why we believe we
just need this fresh start
you know it's interesting isn't it
because um you say that the conservative
got 12 years of misery that they put on
the united kingdom and that there's a
cost of living crisis that labor is the
one with the plan and then the one
policy that you talk about is the
windfall tax that is already happening
anyway
and it also you know is really just a
drop in the ocean if you look at the
what's actually needed it's not really
the radical inspiring vision
that the rhetoric suggests is it
i think what it did was it set out
principle which was the labour party
wants to help people and families right
across the country with their energy
bills and the conservatives who opposed
it until we just put so much pressure on
they were forced to u-turn on it and all
of your candidates have all opposed the
windfall tax throughout the last few
months when we've been debating this
whereas what they were doing was
defending the excess profits of the oil
and gas companies and in the end that's
about who you stand up for do you stand
up for a small number of
private companies that are making excess
profits or do you stand up for the vast
majority of people across the country
who need a fair deal and in the end i
think that is the divide between the
conservatives and labor and it's why all
of the candidates that have put
themselves forward and everybody that's
been involved in these 12 years of
conservative government have been
letting the country down
now uh just finally uh this week you
raised uh the april 2018 meeting between
boris johnson then foreign secretary and
the former and alexander levidev in
italy the former kgb officer without any
officials without any security you say
that go to the heart of our national
security
can you just be clear exactly what
you're alleging here because it is right
to say of course that uh with his stance
on ukraine his relationship with the
ukrainian uh president
you know he he's
he's not exactly under russian influence
is he
i think the issue is whether you have
somebody who is just careless about
national security risks we don't know
what happened at this meeting we don't
know
even whether the prime minister actually
declared the meeting properly or told
officials about it afterwards it just
sort of feels unthinkable that at a time
when we had a chemical attack on uk soil
and it was so serious that we're having
meetings with nato about how to respond
to russia at that time you could have a
foreign secretary then foreign secretary
who would then just go and have a
meeting with an ex-kgb agent someone who
has since been sanctioned by canada for
close links to putin and to have that
meeting at that time shows a careless
disregard for national security risks we
actually need to know the facts about
what happened and the facts about what
action the uh it was taken once boris
johnson returned and why on earth he was
so irresponsible with our national
security at that time